[Muzică]
am și o trăsătură
imediat Bună dimineața dragi pescari ne
aflăm în Delta Dunării la mijlocul lunii
noiembrie și o să încercăm să facem o
partidă de pescuit la crap timpul încă
ne permite să pescuim din barcă ziua
Avem între 8 și 13° seara Sunt cu minus
Dar seara oricum nu pescuiesc bun în
clipul de astăzi o să vă arăt toată
strategia pe care eu o folosesc atunci
când pescuiesc în Delta Dunării
strategie care de fiecare dată mi a adus
rezultate o să vă arăt cap coadă
monturile pe care le fac nada pe care o
folosesc cum nădesc cât nădesc absolut
tot o să vă arăt în acest clip așa că
stați cu mine până la final și vă promit
că o să aveți ce
învăța bun Haideți să începem cu
începutul că pescuit de pe mal sau că
pescuiești din barcă strategia este
aceeași și poți s o aplici în ambele
situații eu ce fac nădesc dimineața
nădesc și seara câte 2 kg 2 kg j de
boiles da nădesc cu boil tare ca să mă
asigur că mi rămâne pe substrat o
perioadă cât mai lungă Deci nu nădesc cu
boil uri solubile cu boil urile
solubile sau peletele solubile pescuiesc
la cârlig ok Bun nădesc dimineața nădesc
și seara pe un loc de pescuit acolo unde
unde voi pescuit bineînțeles localizarea
Este foarte importantă trebuie să ne
gândim ce anotimp avem afară unde ar
putea să fie peștele Ne strângem
informații de la localnicii întrebăm
unde s a prins în ce zonă s a prins și
de acolo începem să ne începem să ne
căutăm locuri cum am făcut și eu astăzi
Da Aici am Sunt un canal pe lângă pe
lângă Crișan pe Dunărea Veche aproape de
Dunărea Veche și am și o trăsătură
imediat
îl forțez un pic ca să nu se ducă în
cioate îl țin un pic E bine că s a dus
în larg Și de aici Pot să l controlez
cum vreau
Da a trecut și o barcă pe lângă
mine pe lanseta asta în Fir textil de
015 o să vă povestesc puțin mai târziu
Ce este de ce pescuiesc cu Fir
textil Ia să
vedem Deci deși este jumătatea lunii
noiembrie mai exact cred că suntem pe 18
noiembrie peștele încă încă
are încă are forță încă este destul de
activ Ia uitați ce drill frumos acuma se
duce
lângă barcă o să l forțez un pic Oho
Ăsta are 4 kg ca Popa Ia uitați Ce
frumos este de fapt nu l vedeți o să
încerc să dau drumul la ochelari ca să
fac un film și o să vi l pun Deci Delta
Dunării jumătatea lunii noiembrie un
frumos crav de 4
kg cred că are 4 kg Sper să nu mă înșel
o să iau
minciogul Da are 4 kg 100%
așa Ia
uitați Ce frumos este doar ce m am
instalat n am aruncat de 10 minute și a
venit un Superb Superb crab de Dunăre și
Haideți să vă arăt și la ce l am
prins cu nada ged fi în căpșună pentru
ape sălbatice și dumble urile solubile
gda Fishing da
o să încerc imediat să vi l arăt și la
cameră o secundă să liniștească
o
secundă foarte
frumos
așa ușor ușa Deci foarte
frumos foarte energici cpii ăștia am am
reușit să liniște să vi l arăt la
cameră parcă aș avea și două mâini
stângi
ușor deci în timp ce vorbeam cu voi a
venit acest Superb crap Ia uitați l cred
că are 4 kg 4 kg j la dumble urile gda
Fishing cele solubile exact cum De fapt
nu v am zis mai devreme dar o să vi le
prezint Da deci așa arată
[Muzică]
am scos peștele Am obosit un
pic Sunt singur pe barcă Și din păcate
este destul de greu să și filmez să
prind și peste să și pregătesc să vă
prezint la camere să fac și poze mi am
pus telefonul să fac poze pe pe suport
bun povesteam despre strategia gda
Fishing care mă spuneam că aproape de
fiecare dată funcționează și după cum
ați văzut n am ajuns mai mult de nu am
mai mult de 15 20 de minute și deja am
prins un pește de 4
kg bun strategia este în felul
următor trebuie să găsești peștele Ok
trebuie să localizez peștele să întreb
localnicii unde se prinde În ce zonă se
prinde în funcție de anotimp
și localizând peștele o să ai cele mai
mari șanse bun nada pe care eu o
folosesc de fapt eu de foarte multe ori
pe stres la momitor și la momitor pun
nada gda Fishing de cele mai multe ori
de
căpșună iar la cârlig pun dumble urile
sau bois urile solubile gda Fishing pe
care o să vi le prezint un pic mai
încolo nu se găsesc încă în magazin ca
să le cumpărați dar o să fie un produs
care Probabil o să l producem din luna
decembrie Da o să vi o să vi l prezint
un pic mai încolo și o să încerc să vă
mai dau câteva ponturi pe parcurs fac
filmări și cu telefonul și cu GoPro ul
pentru că v am zis că sunt singur și mi
este foarte greu să scot GoPro ul de pe
barcă ă de pe suportul de pe barcă să l
pun să filmez să filmez lucrurile de
detaliu bun vreau să vă arăt ceva
acum mai devreme am prins un am prins
peștele de 4 kg și un pic
și când am verificat
cârligul el nu mai înțeapă Da deci este
foarte important ca noi să verificăm
Cârligele după fiecare pește pentru că
altfel nu o să mai avem prezentări nu se
vede pe cameră dar cârligul acestui
cârlig i s a i s a strâmbat vârful și și
nu mai înțeapă Ia uitați Cum fac eu cu
degetul și pe mine nu Măi înțeapă și
atunci o să schimb cârligul și o să pun
un alt cârlig Eu folosesc cârlige de opt
Da în perioada asta a anului folosesc
cârlige de opt în pe vară folosesc
cârlige de șase Ok Așa arată Așa arată
cârligul meu eu le am deja pregătite o
să încerc să
pun un dumble
uitați Cum arată dumble ul cum este
legat la mine o să vă arăt mai încolo
Cum se leagă și Cârligele cum le leg eu
Da Acesta este un cârlig de opt este un
cârlig subțire nu este un cârlig cu
gros ăsta este dumble ul și aici am un
opritor Da și aici am iar Un opritor ca
dumble ul să nu mi se ducă pe firul de
părți
spre spre spre cârlig iar rigul este în
jur de 8 9 cm și pescuiesc cu să mă uit
și pe cameră să văd dacă se vede bine da
și PES cu momitoare
de acestea sunt de 120 de g nada gda
Fishing încă se vede aici pe momitor Și
acuma ce voi face voi schimba cârligul
aici Eu vă recomand să folosiți un Quick
change Pentru că atunci o să puteți să
schimbați rapid cârligul eu am niște
Quick change uri cumpărate de la un
magazin
dar din păcate au un defect de fabrică
și Îmi taie rigul Adică dacă prind dacă
prind rigul de el și am un pește Îmi
taie rigul pentru că este acolo ascuțit
Unde se prinde cârligul și atunci a
trebuit să renunț la ele și Norocul meu
că am am la mine vârteje da ok o să o să
pun aici
un am tăiat
cârligul Da foarfecele astea de la haku
sun foarte bune
dar după un timp încep să nu mai taie
sau nu știu eu s o reglez că se reglează
de aici
Ok Și acum o să pun cârligul nou ce vă
recomand eu este să vă legați Cârligele
direct de acasă Eu mi le am legat aseară
la cazare de fapt azi dimineață mi le am
legat ca să nu stau pe barcă să le
cârlige mi am legat câte patru din
fiecare am legat și cârlige mai micuțe
firul textil pe care î folosesc este un
fir de
020 dar este un fir moale și este
destinat mai mult
cred că mai mult pentru Feeder este
firul ăsta este foarte subțire Deci nici
nu zici că are 0,20 de mm Mai degrabă
0,16 da ok am pus cârligul Asta este
ăsta
Este dumble ul peleta solubilă
Da Aici am
momitorul și Haideți să vă arăt cum pun
Cum pun Cum pun nada pe mum mitor Deci
Iau iau puțină nadă din găleată O
frământ da Deci asta trebuie să fie
textura nadei o frământ Bine bine o
frământ înainte după care o pun pe
momitor eu mai aveam nadă pe momitor dar
nu este nicio problemă că o să se prindă
de
ea Da Și așa arată am recuperat altă
lansetă și urmează să i schimb să i
schimb bois ul și o să vă arăt și cum
fac lucrul acesta o să verific și
cârligul da Și mai vreau să vă arăt
ceva Eu pun opritoare pe fir de ce pun
opritoare pe fir pentru că vreau să se
facă auto înțepare mulți spun că dacă se
Dacă punem opritoare pe fir și se rupe
firul principal cumva că nu i dăm nicio
șansă peștelui să scape pentru că
rămâne cu mum itorul atrnat de de bot
dar nu este adevărat și o să vă arăt și
de ce Ia uitați în momentul în care
peștele smucește din cap
momitorul se duce în spate și se poate
elibera peștele Da deci dacă eu am aici
opritor chiar dacă am opritor peștele dă
când dă din cap
se poate să scape de momitor Da dar de
ce pun eu de ce pun eu opritor pe firul
principal pentru că vreau să se facă
auto înțeparea când peștele
ia cârligul în gură are o greutatea
momitorului și când dă din cap Îl ajută
să se înțepe să se înțepe ajută cârligul
să se înțepe în Buza peștelui Da deci
cam așa se întâmplă lucrul ăsta îl
folosesc și la momitoarele de Feeder
adică același lucru același principiu
este și acolo Doar că acolo folosesc un
Quick change care ajută la auto înțepare
bun acum o să schimb aici Am avut bois o
să pun tot
bois ois urile acestea sunt solubile și
fiind
solubile fiind solubile ele la 40 de
minute Se topesc le am făcut special
solubile pentru că vreau să se activeze
foarte repede în în apă să înceapă să se
topească foarte repede în apă ca să
atragă cât mai repede peștele ca să
generez cât mai repede trăsătura Da Asta
este Logica lor Acuma este un pic mai
mult de muncă pentru că trebuie să
schimbi la 30 40 de minute dacă nu ai
trăsătură trebuie să schimbi pentru că
rămâi fără rămâi fără boil la cârnic Da
bun am schimbat bois ul Așa arată
montura
mea Și acum o să pun și nadă pe momitor
Și mai vreau să vă spun mai vreau să vă
spun un lucru mai devreme în primul
drill v am zis că pe lansete am Fir
textil de
0,15 sau 0,14 Oricum este destul de este
destul de subțire fire da Eu folosesc
fire de fire textile pe Dunăre pentru că
vreau atunci când pescuiesc în curent să
să am un fir cât mai subțire ca acesta
să nu pună rezistență în curentul apei
și să mi ridice momitorul de pe substrat
Da dacă pescuim pe sulin unde curentul
este mare e e o este indicat sau eu cel
puțin Vă recomand să folosiți fire
textile subțire dar trebuie să aveți
subțiri dar trebuie să aveți grijă
pentru că în drill nu mai aveți
elongația firului și trebuie să lucrați
foarte mult din frână foarte bine din
frână Adică trebuie să vă pricepeți să
lucrați din frână pentru că altfel o să
o să pierdeți montura o să se
rupă
sau posibil să rupeți buza peștelui Da
Deci trebuie să lucrați
din din frână Ia uitați Cum arată Din
punctul meu de vedere montura perfect
Haideți să vă explic Care este logica
momitorului De ce se pescuiește De ce
pescuiesc eu cu momitor pe pe Dunăre
Gândiți vă că momitorul pică în apă și
pică contracurent Da deci de aici vine
curentul și așa Ne stă nouă momitorul în
apă Ok Și de aici vine curentul cârligul
nostru va fi luat de curent și va fi dus
la distanță Dar ce se întâmplă cu toată
nada de pe momitor ea se va desface și
va crea o dâră de nadă care se va duce
bine se va duce mai departe de cârlig
dar cârligul nostru se află se află pe
această dâră Da și peștele vine și
mănâncă pe acea dâră absoarbe nada
noastră și printre nada noastră Găsește
și cârligul împreună cu dumble ul sau
cu cu bois ul da Deci asta este logica
momitorului de asta se folosesc
momitoare pe
Dunăre contraindicate sunt momitoarele
când aveți pește mic pe vad Adică
dacă aveți plătică aveți caras ei vor
veni să mănânce de pe acest momitor și
atunci trebuie să renunțați la momitor
să pescuiți doar la boil cu plumb normal
Da cu plumb inline Dar asta se întâmplă
de obicei vara eu Eu oricum pescuiesc în
majoritatea cazurilor cu momitor doar
atunci când am mult pește mic pe vad
schimb și folosesc momitoare inline bun
montura este pregătită o lansez și pe
aceasta și așteptăm următoarea
prezentare Să nu credeți că pescuitul în
Deltă este ușor Ieri am avut un început
de partidă
extraordinar la prima lansare Am prins
un crab de aproape 5 kg 5 c și un
pic după care s a tăiat efectiv nu a mai
prins niciun pește până seara am tot
încercat am tot încercat am nădit am
schimbat cârligi am pus cârlige mai
micuțe am făcut tot ce știam eu mai bine
să fac și nu am mai prins pește de ce
Pentru că
de două zile în de fapt de două zile de
o săptămână și ceva dacă nu mai bine Apa
este în scădere și ce se întâmplă eu am
pescuit pe un canal Care este un canal
de tranzit este un canal care face
legătura dintre un lac și Dunărea
Dunărea principală și atunci peștele era
în Tranzit acolo când m am pus pe a
ieșit și soarele Ce bine că mai devreme
a ploa dacă mă vedeți sunt
cu sunt cu pelerina de ploaie pe mine ă
deci a scăzut a scăzut apa și peștele
este în Tranzit când m am pus pe locul
acela Probabil că am avut pește pe vad
după care a dispărut tot peștele ă
astăzi sunt pe un alt canal am venit pe
apă mai adâncă pescuiesc pe 4 m ieri
pescuiam pe apă de 2,5 m astăzi
pescuiesc pe apă de 4 m presiunea
atmosferică a scăzut și atunci peștele
se va duce se va duce la la fundul apei
Da pescuiesc pe un canal tot pe lângă
Crișan a plouat mai devreme a plouat
destul de mult
și am ajuns dar nu am reușit să încep
filmarea pentru că mi se Uda camera am
prins în jur de cinci pești între 2 kg
și 3 kg și undeva la șapte ciortani iar
acum pentru că a ieșit soarele și este
frumos O să las camera pornită și o să
filmăm câteva drill uri o să vă arăt cum
am pescuit astăzi pentru că am schimbat
ceva în în strategie am practic dumble
urile pe care vi le am arătat ieri le am
tăiat le am făcut ca un dreptunghi ca
să ca să se activeze mai repede să fie o
momeală mai mică
ok Bun Așteptăm să vină prezentările
Haideți să vă arăt un pic locul pe care
pescuiesc Deci eu pescuiesc aici undeva
în mijlocul canalului apare în jur de 4
m am ajuns dimineață și am nădit cu boil
uri tari am dat și câteva boil uri
solubile ca să se activeze mai repede
peștele și
acum Mă rog am prins pește mai devreme
înainte să dau drumul la cameră am mai
prins un pește un Ciortan de un kg iar
acum iar acum aștept următoarea
prezentare Haideți să vă mai povestesc
un pic despre strategia pe care eu o
aplic atunci când pescuiesc în Delta
Dunării în principiu dacă pescuiesc vara
fac Pad
nadă momesc dimineață și seara câte 2 kg
2 kg și j De ce fac lucrul ăsta pentru
că vreau să mi strâng peștele pe vad și
când vine pe Vadul meu să aibă ce mânca
eu pe Eu fac fac nădire cu boil uri tari
pentru că vreau să rămână cât mai mult
pe substrat Dacă aș face cu boils urile
solubile acestea s
ar s ar desface mai repede și s ar topi
în două trei ore și atunci nu va mai
rămâne nimic pe substrat pentru că le
spală apa și tot ce se dezintegrează din
ele se ia cu se duce adică ia curentul
și duce duce la
val eu pescuiesc la CLI cu boil uri
solubile acum super solubile aș putea să
spun de ce Pentru că vreau să se
activeze foarte repede foarte repede
peștele Să se activeze foarte repede pe
substrat și să atragă cât mai repede
peștele
să să generez trăsătura rapid Da De
multe ori eu și tai bois urile le fac în
pătrat sau dacă pescuiesc cu pelete cu
dumble u le fac ca și dreptunghi ca să
se activeze și mai repede Da sau mai
este o variantă în care le las într un
borcan într un borcan Să se să se
înmoaie
Ok asta asta cu asta pescuiesc la cârlig
deci de fiecare dată Eu nu pun porumb în
Delta Dunării nu pun absolut nimic
altceva decât dumble uri
sau boil uri solubile
Da
există să zic
așa pescari care pescuiesc cu mămăligă
la în Delta Dunării și nu este de loc
greșit să pescu să pescuiești cu
mămăligă sun mai multe rețete de
mămăligă dar Gândiți vă un pic că
mămăliga n are cum să bată un boiles
niciodată pentru că în bois ai mult mai
multe ingrediente
care îi fac pe plac peștelui Care este
Care peștele le consumă și atunci bois
ul are o atractivitate mult mai mare
decât Mămăliga în continuare vă spun că
localizarea este cel mai important lucru
la fel cum spun și în pescuitul la
feeder ați văzut ieri am avut am pescuit
pe o zonă în care am avut pește în prima
parte după care a dispărut peștele Da
Astăzi am venit pe acest loc pentru că
peștele a fost aici am prins cinci pești
O să vă pun câteva poze ca să nu spuneți
că că mint am prins cinci pești de 2 kg
și mai mulți ciortani Da deci 2 3 kg și
mai mulți
ciortani așa
că poți să poți să pescuiești și la
mămăligă poți să poți pescuiești și la
boy list uri dar mai importantă este
localizarea important este să găsești
peștele și după aia să îl ademenești cu
tot felul de tot felul de momeli pe care
pe care le ai
ul ăsta în Delta
Dunării Peștele este destul de
mofturos trăsăturile toate trăsăturile
pe care le am avut în afară de cea de
ieri nu au fost Run uri adică nu mi au
îndoit bățul și să fugă să mi ia fir de
pe de de pe tambur ci efectiv niște
semnale niște semnale foarte slabe pe
Vârful lansetelor dacă vedeți lansetele
pe care eu le folosesc sunt niște
lansete cu vârf moale sunt au o rezervă
mare de putere dar sunt lansete cu vârf
moale pentru că vreau să văd
semnalizările semnalizările cele mai
fine pe care le pe care le face crapul
mai ales în perioada asta a anului
Da Ziceam că el este foarte mofturos nu
se hrănește cum se hrănește vara
deși toamna este toamnă iarnă când apa
are 9 10° este perfect pentru pescuitul
la crab dar am observat că este foarte
foarte apatic Da și drill urile sunt cum
să zic eu ca și cum am scoate un caras
Da deci peștele pare că este amorțit Și
atunci ce am făcut eu astăzi am pescuit
cu cârlige finuțe am pus cârlige de 8 și
de 10 pentru că vreau să vreau să l
păcălesc da dacă i aș pune de șase sau
de patru sunt sigur că ar că le ar ocoli
da Deci eu ce fac vreau să l vreau să l
păcălesc să l păcălesc cu cârligul meu
micuț pescuiesc la
momitor pentru că vreau să am un plus de
atracție în apă să vină peștele să
mănânce de pe momitor iar Cârligele
împreună cu dumble ul tăiat le bag în
nadă dar nu le îngrop în nadă nu le
îngrop în adă în momitor ci efectiv le
pun la suprafață este ca Cireașa de pe
tort o să vă o să vă arăt după ce când o
să încep să le schimb pentru că deja
aici cred că am avut o trăsătură o să
încep să le schimb pentru că deja au
jumătate de oră în apă și o să vă arăt
atunci da Deci când pescuim trebuie să
ne gândim foarte foarte mult la
comportamentul crapului ce face crapul
De ce nu mănâncă și să să schimbăm
lucruri să nu să nu Să nu mergem pe
același lucru sau pe aceeași idee pe
care noi o avem în cap și să zicem că nu
doar așa trebuie să prindem pește Da
deci știm Deci așa arată momitorul meu
cu dumble ul
tăiat acuma este mai mult în dreptunghi
cârligul Este Este băgat aici în nadă
jos și dumble ul deasupra Da îi spun
Cireașa de pe tort acum o să fac
lansarea uitați
trăsătură încerc să l ridic pentru că
acolo am o
[Muzică]
nu e mare repe la 2
kg 1 j
dou vi l arăt imediat și la
cameră ușor ușor
Ia uitați ce frumos
e Ce culoare frumoasă
are vară din nou
Deci la asta a venit crapul de mai
devreme dumble gda
este este tăiat este făcut dreptunghi
cârligul Este băgat în nadă nada cea
[Muzică]
de usturoi pentru ape sălbatice U ce
frumos se văd semințele de
rapiță Și acum o să fac o nouă lansare
și așteptăm din nou un alt pește
normal și
frumos este atunci când treci pe lângă o
barcă sau pe lângă alte bărci în pe
apă să încetinești și să mergi cu viteză
redusă aproape aproape la relantii de ce
Pentru că efectiv deranjez oamenii care
sunt pe mal cum sunt eu aici sunt
ancorat lângă niște creni nu am o
problemă foarte mare dar dacă m aș fi
ancorat lângă mal și malul ar fi avut și
pietre în el mi ar fi zgâriat barca de
la toate valurile care care
vin anul ăsta Am
fost Am fost în Deltă și a trecut pe
lângă mine o barcă o barcă mare și
Mergea
semiglob și se fac niște valuri foarte
mari în spate era o barcă cabinat cred
că de 6 m 6 m și ceva și mi a băgat apă
în barcă practic valul am intrat sub val
și mi a intrat apă în apă în barcă mulți
conducători nu nu și dau seama de lucrul
ăsta dar decât să mergi Sem Mig glisat
adică să reduci viteza și să fii în semi
glisaj este Mai rău decât dacă ai trece
glisat pe lângă o altă barcă pentru că
glisat nu face atât de multe valuri de
fapt atât de mari valurile ca atunci
când când este Sem migl Așa că dacă
printre voi sunt persoane care aveți
bărci vă rog să țineți cont de acest
lucru pentru că deranjați deranjați
ceilalți pescari și Gândiți vă și voi că
atunci când stați ancorați la mal și
trec alții cu viteză nu vă convine așa
că dacă vouă nu vă convine să faceți și
voi la fel da încetiniți Când treceți pe
lângă alte bărci pentru că așa este
normal Și așa este civilizat
[Râsete]
[Muzică]
am din nou trăsătură la asta din dreapta
cea care e dată cel mai în larg Ia să
vedem îl mai las un
pic nu l grăbesc
Da pare
agățat la cum
trage Hai să vedem
și iar treb să l ridic să l duc imediat
să l scot din agăță turri hai hai hai
sus sus sus sus Bravo Cred că Cred că am
scăpat de agăță
tură Da am scăpat de
agățător și
acuma î Băsescu un pic
să Ya un m
chu hop
este
cea pe care am aruncat o
penultima așa vi l arăt imediat să l
vedeți ce frumos și lunguieț este Ia să
i fac și o poză
așa tumble ul
care acuma nu mai este
dumble este un
dreptunghi uitați ce frumos e Ce culoare
frumoasă are
Superb
Superb îi dăm
drumul Ia să dăm dăm și c era un pic mai
așa și
eliberare Deci nici n a apucat să se
ducă nada de pe de pe momitor cârligul
meu cu dumble uri erau băgate în momitor
crapul A venit a mâncat sau e posibil să
se și elibereze de la curent să
elibereze cârligul împreună cu dumble ul
și să cadă să cadă adică să l ia
curentul să l ducă în fața momitorului
bun o să relanseze și așteptăm alte
[Muzică]
capturi Ia uitați trăsătură eram pe
telefon nu eram
atent și cred că mi a luat și celălalt
fir trebuie să văd acuma
cred că s a agățat de ceva a
scăpat Da acolo am o
agățător sunt anemice asta a fost un pic
mai puternică trăsătura a
da cred că am trăsătură și la asta o să
l mai las un pic să văd care i treaba
Pentru că v am zis sunt
anemici și îi lasă să ia baba
[Râsete]
hotărâți Ia uitați din nou
trăsătură ăsta mi ia fir Ăsta i mai
mare Aha
da ăsta i mai
mare și încerc să l scot din agăț din
agățător Da Ăsta i măricel să știți
a e în
agățător I am mai dat un pic drumul la
fir să văd Poate se eliberează
el îl țin un pic în
iune
Hai
nu
Da știți cum e cel mai mare pește e ăla
pe care l am
scăpat da
o să încerc să trag un
pic să văd Poate am
noroc Hai că
parcă da a ieșit a ieșit
Bravo luat firul ăsta se duce în
stuf așa
așa
mă nu sub barcă nu sub
barcă mamă mamă
mamă o sub
barcă așa mă
frumos Ia
uitați
huh Ce m a chinuit
ăsta vi l arăt imediat la
cameră Ia să vedem Și doar ce am aruncat
o pe asta acum cinci
minute deci nu e de mult
cred că are vreo 4 kg
Ia uitați Ce frumos
este să i fac și o poză cu
telefonul Între timp am rămas fără
baterie
la la variere și sper să se audă Ok pe
microfonul de la cameră dacă nu vă rog
frumos să mă Iertați
[Râsete]
urătură
[Muzică]
[Râsete]
se lasă întunericul n o să mai stau mult
ce o să fac acum o să fac nădirea de
seară o să mai nădesc mai mult de 2 kg
jum în jur de vreo 5 kg Pentru că mai
vreau să vin mâini două ore să pescuiesc
Bineînțeles dacă voi găsi locul liber
pentru că au trecut mulți pescari pe
lângă mine și m au întrebat dacă au dacă
am prins și le am zis că am prins eu le
zic tuturor că prind Nu nu mă ascund să
ascund faptul că prind pește și este
posibil să fi ocupat dar asta este o să
fac acuma o nădire de 5 kg o nădire mai
mai masivă după care o să revin
dimineață Vă salut și o seară bună
pentru că la mine se face seara
[Râsete]
[Muzică]
test test
Bună dimineața dragi pescari ne aflăm
din nou pe apă m am trezit
dimineață m am urcat în barcă și am
venit din nou pe locul de pescuit pe
care l am omit aseară Să vedem dacă
Astăzi voi prinde ceva astăzi n o să
pescuiesc mai mult de două trei ore
pentru că va trebui să plec să plec spre
casă Voi nu vedeți dar lucrurile sunt
înghețate azi noapte a fost cu minus
barca era toată înghețată peste tot
aveam gheață mai aveam niște apă în
barcă de ier de la ploaie și era
înghețată
ă Sper să nu influențeze prea mult
apetitul peștelui această scădere bruscă
de temperatură pentru că ieri au fost
afară deși a plouat au fost vreo
14° nu a fost cu minus dar Om vedea Om
vedea ce se
întâmplă acum în prima parte a zilei
este destul de mult trafic pentru că
trec bărcile Ba cei care pleacă în
excursii b pescarii care se duc pe
locurile de pescuit și este un pic un
pic trafic un pic agitație
sper la fel să nu afecteze apetitul
peștelui această agitație eu am întins
lansetele înainte să dau drumul la
cameră Deci au maxim 7 10 minute în
apă pescuiesc la fel cum am pescuit și
ieri cu momitoare cu nada de căpșună gda
Fishing pentru ape sălbatice cu dumble
urile gda Fishing pe care le am tăiat și
le am făcut ca un dreptunghi cu cârlige
mici de opt de 10 pentru că Peștele este
mofturos perioada asta așa că așteptăm
să vedem ce se va întâmpla
azi verifică acum presiunea
atmosferică și dacă Ieri a fost în
scădere Ieri a fost
993 nu scuze 993 astăzi este în creștere
și este 103 ceea ce nu este prea
favorabil pentru pentru pescuitul la
crap dar Om vedea ce se întâmplă
Oricum Peștele este în Tranzit deci pe
canalul ăsta acum El este în Tranzit mai
ales că scade apa mai ales că se răcește
apa se duce și caută apă mai adâncă pe
canalele principale și de aceea am
reușit să prind ier pește pentru că este
pește pe acest canal este în Tranzit
Sper Eu să nu fi plecat să fi ieșit În
brațul principal și să fie încă aici în
în zona asta dacă nu este asta e Ieri am
avut o zi plină de
de pești m am distrat a fost foarte
frumos așa că ăsta este pescuitul mai
ales în Delta Dunării Nu este ușor poți
să prinzi o zi pește a doua zi poți să
nu mai prinzi pește pe același loc
pentru că peștele se mută este valabil
pe perioada asta pe perioada când este
frig afară pe perioada de primăvară el
se mută mult în schimb vara vara este
mai ușor de prins pește în Delta Dunării
pentru că îl găsești adunat în cioate îl
găsești pe
canale spunde bine la patul de nadă eu
am făcut o nădire aseară Sper să
răspundă să să rămână pe loc Adică chiar
dacă era în Tranzit să rămână pe loc pe
patul de nadă să mănânce un pic dar nu
putem să știm pentru că Gândiți vă un
pic dacă apa
scade Instinctul lui de supraviețuire î
zice să se ducă la Apa adâncă asta Ce
înseamnă că nici poftă de mâncare nu ar
avea atât de mult până nu se simte în
siguranță Gândiți vă cum suntem și noi
oamenii când suntem în pericol nu avem
nevoie de mâncare a așa sunt și ei
peștii așteptăm să vedem ce se
întâmplă i ai dat mâncarea asară ca la
balamuc i am dat 5 kg de bile A da am
auzit i am dat multă Stai să vedem
dacă până acuma nimic de jumate de oră
niciun țac
[Muzică]
Ia uitați
trăsătură nu e mare e un Ciortan micuț
dar e un semn bun asta înseamnă că se se
mișcă peștele
mănâncă și asta mă interesează să provoc
una două trăsături pentru că după aia
reușesc eu să prind și pești mai
mari
așa deș un Ciortan micuț nici nu bag
minciogul o să l iau așa
Oricum deja mă pregăteam să le
scot
hop Deci un
ciorăști Deci o să le mai las pe
celelalte așa
Deci Apa este foarte foarte rece mi a
înghețat mâna pe
Pește Nu știu cât are apa acuma o să mă
uit pe cotele apelor să văd cât a scăzut
pentru că ier alaltă ar avea 9,5 10°
apă Este dificil pescuitul de iarnă
pentru că efectiv îți îngheață mâna Deci
orice i face dacă pui nadă pe momitor
dacă te ștergi mai ales să te speli în
apă acuma
î Dar ce nu facem noi pentru pescuit
nu un un nod Da Și după aia se bagă prin
Cârlig din interior către exterior
legați cu Fir textil Fir textil am pe
mulinetă Fir textil Bun A deci atât
Da Din astea Am și apăi cu din astea așa
mici ai prin crăpă lă Da da da de opt de
10 astea s de 10 merg și alea de că și
alea s No din alea am nu i problemă a
Păi atunci așa le
[Muzică]
[Râsete]
faceți Eu v am mai zis lucrul ăsta și vă
mai zic dacă aveți ocazia să ajutați un
coleg pe scar cu cârlige cu monturi cu
momeală Cu ce se poate Ajutați i pentru
că este posibil la la un moment dat să
aveți și voi nevoie pe mine m au ajutat
mulți pe scari pe baltă când n am avut
ceva așa că și eu ajut la rândul meu și
vă recomand să faceți și voi asta pentru
că este un gest
frumos mi am pus o mânușă de silicon
pentru că mi a înghețat mâna când pun
nada pe momitor și o să încerc să pun cu
mânușa asta să văd dacă mai î îngheață
ia am și
trăsătură Ia să vedem a slăbit firul
îi e Da
aici b în am munte
Bravo Nu pare
mare Tot așa Ciortan cred că este dar de
distracție astăzi oricum nu aveam prea
multe speranțe că voi prinde pește aici
pentru că s a răcit foarte foarte rău
presiunea atmosferică a
crescut Ia să l iau cu minciogul pe ăsta
că pare un pic mai
măricel Deci e bine că se
hrănește ăsta este lovit
Deci trăsătura mi a venit la lanseta
asta
după o oră o oră și 10 minute
uitați l și pe acesta și Ia uitați l e
rănit n am și prea antiseptic la mine
pentru că i aș fi dat Dacă aș fi avut
dar un nou Ciortan doi ciortani într o
oră de când am venit o oră și 10 minute
Cam așa le am Deci de când le am aruncat
o oră și 10
minute încă ceva Vreau să vă arăt în
momentul în care luați să puneți nada pe
de pe să puneți nada pe momitor
încercați s o frământați un pic în mână
înainte Da adică să n o puneți direct
așa pentru că este posibil să se desfacă
Deci dacă eu o frământ uitați ce textură
face Da ca să vă reziste cât mai mult pe
momitor v am mai spus despre pescuit că
dacă vrei să ai rezultate bune trebuie
să ai foarte multe informații despre
despre
pește dacă vrei să ai partide reușite
îți recomand să adun cât mai multe
informații despre pescuitul în Delta
Dunării și bineînțeles orice tip de
pescuit pe care îl practici când vine
vorba de Delta Dunării și de Informații
să știți că informațiile puteți să le
aflați în primul rând de la localnici de
la alți pescari și cum Aflați toate
aceste
informații mergând la cazări mergând la
gazde de obicei la localnici unde merg
și alți pescari Și de multe ori o să
găsiți pescari experimentați care seara
la masă discută despre pescuit spun
experiența pe care au avut o ziua în
ziua în care au pescuit și așa mai
departe vă arată monturi vă arată nadă
cu care
pescuiesc este așa o o mică comunitate
care se formează la fiecare gazdă
care își dă spre închiriere camerele
într adevăr camerele sunt modeste nu ai
aceleași nu ai Aceleași condiții ca la
hotelurile de trei stele dar credeți mă
că informațiile acolo le găsiți Pentru
că acolo vă întâlniți cu pescari cu
experiență și puteți să învățați foarte
multe lucruri și cu cât aveți mai multe
informații despre pescuit cu atât veți
reuși să prindeți mai mult pește eu am
încercat să vă dau mai multe informații
despre pescuit despre pescuitul în Delta
Dunării nu pot să vi le dau pe toate o
dată pentru că dacă nu mă întâlnesc cu
ele nici eu nu mi aduc aminte ce pot să
vă zic este să vă puneți mereu mai multe
întrebări despre pescuit ce face peștele
acum de ce
De ce nu mănâncă De ce mănâncă sau când
ați prins pește de ce ați prins pește
mereu să vă puneți întrebări pentru că
așa veți găsi soluții dacă doar lansați
aruncați lansetele într o anumită zonă
și așteptați să prindeți pește de cele
mai multe ori se întâmplă să nu prindeți
și Poate vi s a întâmplat asta până
acum exact ce
spuneam cu pescarii de pescarii de
duminică sau navigatorii de duminică sau
poate că chiar nu știu despre lucrul
ăsta a trecut din nou o barcă pe lângă
mine o barcă cabinat o barcă mare o
barcă grea care m a văzut bineînțeles
și în loc să reducă de tot a redus un
pic A intrat în semiglob foarte foarte
mari care aproape mi au băgat apă în
barcă din nou vă spun dacă faceți acest
lucru și nu știți nu e nicio problemă
dacă nu știți dar învățați să vă opriți
pe loc
Sau să mergeți efectiv în glisaj pentru
că în semi glisaj se fac niște valuri
foarte foarte
mari am avut noroc de data asta nu mi e
intrat apă în barcă dar vedem la
următoarea
tură Ia să vedem dacă e mai mare
decât
restul Dar nu
pare pare tot așa
micuț dar ne distrăm azi ne
distrăm
Da e un pic mai mare decât restul
Sau cred că mi se pare cred că i la
fel vi l arăt imediat
boaba de fapt
dreptunghiul
dreptunghiul nada care încă este pe
momitor și acum
ACA un pește sănătos de Dunăre pe care l
eliberăm am și o întrebare că am
încercat i tot așa Tu dai la bois uri
sau la Da la niște dumble uri Nu prea mă
pr
Vino să ți dau câteva bag Da Bagă te pe
partea
asta
așa la Marea captură Deci fii atent Așa
arată CH aia plutesc Nu nu plutesc a ST
apă
dai pe momitor atât at ia Mulțumesc Asta
ai să prinzi Fii atent și le faci așa le
tai cu un Cutter sau cu un cuțit Da și
le faci așa pătrate Da bine dreptunghi
Așa da și pescuiești cu cârlig cu cârlig
micuț de opt de 10 de 10a Da e perfect e
perfect Se pare că astăzi crapul nu prea
mănâncă am vorbit deja cu vreo doi trei
pescari la telefon care sunt diferite
locuri și n au prins nimic nici măcar
Ciortan n au prins și cei care au mai
trecut cu bărcile pe aici am mai vorbit
cu ei și la fel n au prins
pește cred că cumva unul dintre motive
poate să fie presiunea atmosferică Ieri
a fost mai scăzută astăzi iar a
urcat ăsta poate să fie unul dintre
motive la mine Na au au intrat trei
cortan dar nimic notabil peștișor micuți
i ați văzut pe cameră acum mai așteptăm
să vedem care Hai să vedem Care este
situația eu nu mai pot să pescuiesc mai
mult de o oră și jumătate dacă mai iau
ceva într o oră și jumătate bine dacă nu
merg spre casă și a fost oricum o
partidă o partidă frumoasă pentru mine
or
cură
Da este un Ciortan
Deci al patrulea pește pe ziua de astăzi
în câteva ore oricum mai am de gând să
stau un pic și să plec
[Muzică]
și acesta este lovit nu știu ce are pe
aici Cum se întâmplă lucrul ăsta Dar o
să l eliberăm și pe
acesta ai am o trăsătură
nu a
scăpat asta a fost tot dragi pescari
partida mea de pescuit în drepta Dunării
s a încheiat am avut o partidă cu de
toate Am avut lapoviță și n sare Am avut
2 3° noaptea am avut și căldură Acum a
început să bată vântul foarte tare
nu știu cât de bine mă auziți pe
microfon dar de aici s a pornit așa o
semi
furtună nu mai stau strâng sculele mă
duc la cazare îmi iau bagajul și o iau
spre Tulcea partida de pescuit s a
încheiat cu succes Din punctul meu de
vedere am avut ieri o zi plină de pește
am prins pește toată ziua dimineața a
plouat și n am reușit să filmez dar când
când s a potolit ploaia am pus camera și
am filmat
dacă aveți întrebări despre pescuitul în
Delta
Dunării despre momelile pe care să le
folosiți despre strategie Vă rog frumos
să mi lăsați în comentarii sau să mi
trimiteți pe mail contactar gda
fishing.ro iar toate nadele o să le
găsiți pe gda fishing.ro boy list urile
și tumble urile încă nu sunt scoase la
vânzare o să încercăm să le facem din
decembrie sau din ianuarie vor fi
vândute la borcănașe micuțe și boy list
urile pentru nădit o să fie vândute la
saci de 5 sau de 10 kg o să vedem sau
ambele atât din Delta Dunării Vă
mulțumesc frumos că ați urmărit până la
sfârșit și ne vedem la următoarea
partidă ah